tous bienvenue à Besançon nous sommes au
pied de la citadelle sur les bords du
Doubs pour une émission spéciale
consacrée ce matin au scrutin régional
de décembre prochain et pour la première
fois on élira un concert régional de
Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui en sera le
président et bien on en débat maintenant
dans la voie libre
2 millions 800000 habitants 8
départements 71 millions d'euros de
richesse produit chaque année et bientôt
un ou une présidente qui dirigera la
future grande région Bourgogne
Franche-Comté nous avons réuni ce matin
pour une émission spéciale soulevant et
sur la terrasse de la Rodia la
magnifique terrasse de la salle de
musique actuelle de Besançon
quelques-uns des principaux candidats à
cette élection Eric oui 5 candidats pour
être précis Mary kit du fait tout
d'abord bonjour vous êtes la présidente
socialiste sortante du Conseil Régional
de Franche-Comté et vous êtes candidate
à l'investiture du PS pour l'instant
seul candidate déclaré Alain je voyais
bonjour sénateur UMP de Haute-Saône vous
avez été secrétaire d'État mère
conseiller général puis conseiller
régional et vous êtes le chef de fil
désigné par l'UMP pour ces élections à
côté de vous Christophe grüdler bonjour
vous êtes conseiller départemental de
Belfort et vous êtes la tête de liste du
Modem c'est si le Prudhomme bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la tête de liste
investissez ce dimanche par Europe
Écologie Les Verts et Maxime Thiébaut
bonjour tête de liste pour debout la
France 24 ans vous êtes juriste
spécialisé dans les collectivités
territoriales alors précisons que nous
avions également invité les deux autres
candidats déclarés à savoir l'UDI
François Sauvadet et la fn Sophie Montel
mais que tous les deux ont décliné notre
invitation alors Mesdames Messieurs au
cours de ce débat nous allons évoquer
ensemble la situation politique les
ambitions de chacun d'entre vous les
conditions de réussite de la fusion
entre nos deux régions et puis
évidemment vos projets pour cette grande
région Bourgogne Franche-Comté notamment
en matière économie l'économie ce sera
la principale compétence des futurs
conseils régionaux je précise que vous
aussi devant votre téléviseur vous
pouvez participer à cette émission en la
commentant sur les réseaux sociaux grâce
aux mots # qui s'affiche lvl BFC pour
une fois lvl comme la voix Élie BFC
comme Bourgogne Franche-Comté té Eric on
y va oui alors tout d'abord on va
s'arrêter à vos candidatures à la
situation politique à votre situation
personnelle à chacun d'entre vous Marie
guide du fait alors vous êtes donc
candidate à la candidature au PS je l'ai
dit pour l'instant vous êtes seul mais
il se dit que il y a un sondage qui est
commandé par votre partie en interne
alors est-ce que vous êtes certaine
d'aller au bout et sinon est-ce que ce
sondage sera décisif
écoutez ce sera un élément dans la prise
de décision au sein du parti mais je
suis déterminé effectivement à être
candidate et je suis heureuse de cette
candidature ça veut dire qu'il y aura
une éventuellement une primaire interne
éventuellement comment vous réagissez
quand vous lisez dans la presse comme
nous j'imagine que François Hollande et
cette poussée son ministre du Travail
ancien maire de Dijon François hepsomen
pour être candidat en quelque sorte à
votre place je l'ai pas vraiment entendu
et j'ai pas vraiment d'éléments qui qui
me sont allés directement sur ce sujet
et François Patriat c'est un concurrent
éventuel on dit qu'il hésite alors qu'il
est
vous me permettrez de ne pas répondre
alors dites nous au moins quels sont vos
atouts vous êtes la seule femme
socialiste sortante ça est-ce que c'est
un atout et un atout important
dans le cadre de la primaire au sein du
Parti socialiste c'est ce que vous
voulez me faire dire oui ou pour pour la
décision du Parti socialiste écoutez
première à tous c'est que je suis assez
fière et contente du bilan et du travail
que nous avons fait alors je sais bien
que tout cela c'est du passé et que ce
qui est important c'est de se projeter
dans l'avenir mais la force qui nous a
fait travailler pendant quatre ans cinq
ans c'est la même force qui m'anime pour
le futur en plus j'ai manifesté une
détermination certaine sur le
rapprochement de nos deux régions et
j'ai envie d'aller jusqu'au bout et de
prolonger ce travail qui a été initié il
y a un an Marie Guy Duffé vous êtes la
seule femme présidente de région
sortante est-ce que ce n'est pas aussi
un atout dans un parti qui met souvent
en avant la parité sans forcément la
respecter d'ailleurs écoutez je n'aime
pas du tout cet entrée femme alors je
pense qu'il n'y a pas assez de femmes ça
c'est clair et je regrette d'être la
seule mais je pense que mes atouts c'est
pas des atouts de femmes c'est mes
atouts par rapport aux compétences que
j'ai pu développer au sein de la
responsabilité que j'ai exercé mais
c'est cela le plus important
vous a toujours pas investi même si vous
êtes désigné chef de fil alors qu'est-ce
qu'attend Nicolas Sarkozy est-ce que il
n'a pas tranché entre vous et François
Sauvadet écoutez je voudrais quand même
faire une mise au point aujourd'hui je
comprends pas d'ailleurs cette cette
discussion qui revient fréquemment
contrairement aux parties socialistes où
il n'y a toujours pas de candidats je
redis je répète que au sein de l'UMP les
choses sont claires je suis investi
comme chef de fil de l'UMP pour les 8
départements pour la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté aucun autre candidat
d'ailleurs ne s'est fait connaître la
commission nationale d'investiture m'a
élu à l'unanimité le conseil national de
l'UMP a fait de même donc les choses
sont très claires oui mais il y a quand
même des distances vous le savez bien il
y a des il y a des UMP qui sont derrière
François Sauvadet on peut s'interroger
François Sauvadet a déclaré sa
candidature en tant que
udi les choses sont normales
j'attends de voir s'il effectivement des
UMP derrière sa candidature c'est pas du
tout la même chose qu'un appel à l'union
on est là dans une candidature coûtait
franchement je pense que si monsieur
sauvadev vous laisse s'exprimer je crois
vous l'avez invité il a pas voulu venir
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il refuse un
débat et au fond nous sommes pas frères
jumeaux avec le Daily mais nous sommes
quand même dans la même famille
politique moi je ne me trompe pas
d'adversaire il y a un candidat à l'UDI
c'est naturel il y a un candidat à l'UMP
c'est naturel que chacun ait son projet
que chacun travaille que chacun fasse
campagne et ensuite les électeurs
décideront mais en tout cas où ça l'UMP
je le redis les choses sont parfaitement
claires est-ce que ce n'est pas prendre
un risque néanmoins pour votre camp de
partir diviser on sait que vos
présidents respectifs monsieur Lagarde
Monsieur Sarkozy pour l'UMP on vanter
cette union dès le premier tour qui a
permis à la droite de conquérir un
nombre très important de département là
vous partirez divisé en tout cas vous
jouez cette carte là on dirait moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord je l'ai je
l'ai dit je le redis évidemment pour
conduire une liste
UMP
udi voire au-delà n'est-ce pas
Christophe grudeler donc il y a aucun
problème j'ai toujours été un homme de
rassemblement l'UMP aujourd'hui est la
force politique majeure de ces 8
départements l'UMP a donc toute la
légitimité pour conduire cette liste
d'union mais si l'UDI veut absolument
faire de liste écoutez on se retrouvera
ultérieurement c'est pas grave donc
c'est l'union d'accord mais derrière moi
seulement écoutez l'UMP lui département
15000 militants 21 parlementaires sur 25
dont 16 qui sont à mon comique 15 qui
sont à mon comité de soutien au nom de
quoi l'UMP ne conduirait pas cette hize
j'ajoute que je suis en campagne depuis
5 mois aujourd'hui nous avons fait un
travail considérable avec des centaines
de personnes déjà je me suis consacré
exclusivement à cette élection régionale
j'ai envie de dire je suis prêt vous ne
reculerez parce que tout à l'heure
j'espère que tout à l'heure on pourra
justement aborder la question du projet
le projet m'intéresse beaucoup tout le
reste et Bizzbee politique je pense que
vraiment nos concitoyens
peu moins sur cette question est-ce que
vous êtes en contact avec François
sauvalet écoutez je lui ai rendu visite
il y a quelques temps dans son bureau du
conseil général de département de la de
la Côte d'Or il est président du conseil
général de la Côte d'Or moi je me suis
consacré à ses élections régionales donc
évidemment qu'il faut parler nous sommes
encore une fois dans le même dans le
même camp politique il faudrait bien sûr
se rassembler pour pour gagner mais je
ne vois pas pourquoi ce ne serait pas
naturel qu'au fond chaque formation
politique et un chef de fil dans une
élection à la proportionnelle d'ailleurs
je vois pas pourquoi ça fait tellement
je ne vois pas
si c'est votre question c'est moi qui
fait la réponse il vous permettez je
vois pas pourquoi ça fait autant de
débats au moment où par exemple les
Verts viennent de décider d'avoir leur
propre liste et c'est bien légitime dans
une élection à la proportionnelle donc
toutes ces vieux l'UDI aimerait faire
l'union tout est bien tout va bien l'UMP
aussi souhaite faire l'union mais en
tout cas oui ça l'UMP unanimité derrière
ma candidature avec cette commission
nationale d'investiture et le Conseil
évidemment national de l'UMP qui a qui a
réglé tout ça donc je vois pas pour moi
il y a pas de débat les choses sont très
très claires il faut travailler sur un
projet elle présentait à nos concitoyens
candidat suivant
alors vous vous venez tout juste un
d'être investi mais il y a plusieurs
votes qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
avec François loto donc qui est le
bourguignon qui était aussi sur les
rangs et qui qu'est-ce qui a pesé en
votre faveur
on est super attaché à la parité et
super attaché au renouvellement je suis
une femme j'ai jamais eu de mandat et
donc voilà il fallait une parité
nationale tous les votes des militants
nationalement ont dispatché les régions
il y a eu 6 femmes 6 hommes et voilà
donc il y a pas du tout de guerre avec
François loto que ce soit clair pourquoi
partir avec une liste autonome vous avez
des élus en Bourgogne des élus en
Franche-Comté ils font tous partie des
majorités sortantes des majorités à
dominantes socialistes derrière Marie
guide Dufay et François Patriat pourquoi
ne pas assumer le bilan
c'est pas qu'on assume pas le bilan
c'est qu'on a d'autres choses à dire et
en cette année de la COP 21 par exemple
sommet mondial du climat qui tiendra à
Paris en décembre il est essentiel que
Europe Écologie Les Verts puisse porter
les idées qu'elle défend et notamment
la transition écologique et on a plein
de choses à dire sur la transition
écologique dans les territoires ouais
mais quand on voit le les résultats
au dernier élections d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts on peut se dire que c'est
aussi courir le risque d'être éliminé au
premier tour parce qu'il faut atteindre
oui alors bon déjà on est déjà parti en
autonome régional 2010 où on avait fait
moins de 10% ben moi 10% mais il faut 5%
pour oui et 10% pour se maintenir bon on
espère être dans
au mieux en plus de 10 et où à 5% et
puis vous étiez tout juste au-dessus de
9 et demi dans les deux régions mais le
contexte était peut-être plus porteur
pour vous exactement mais bon on repasse
de l'autre côté du plateau
Eric avec Christophe Grudler on parlait
d'union à droite peut-être qu'il a des
choses à nous dire là on a vu à la joie
déjà la perche dès ses premières phrases
rapidement vous voyez bien que je suis
un homme de l'Union alors justement
pourquoi monter une liste MoDem est-ce
que c'est pour faire un peu pression
est-ce que on sait que vous êtes plutôt
proche un modem de droite comme on dit
est-ce que je suis le centre indépendant
donc le Mouvement Démocrate est un
centre indépendant et qui tient à le
rester ceci étant nous avons un constat
en Bourgogne Franche-Comté c'est que il
y a clairement deux régions en situation
d'échec la Bourgogne et la Franche-Comté
jusqu'à maintenant et que pour demain il
nous faut un nouveau souffle pour la
région pour une Franche-Comté et dans ce
cadre là le centre dont j'incarne les
valeurs du Mouvement Démocrate souhaite
un rassemblement large pour mettre en
place une nouvelle dynamique alors
concrètement donc concrètement ça veut
dire que nous sommes favorables une
liste de rassemblement et d'union avec
nos partenaires potentiels de l'UDI et
de l'UMP donc j'appelle rassemblement
bien évidemment dans le respect du poil
électoral des uns et des autres sinon à
la joie Andenne je me proposerai pour le
dans le respect du point électoral des
autres ce que je vous propose sinon
c'est de combien d'aliments
moi je propose éventuellement si on
tient pas compte du poids électoral je
peux conduire la liste de rassemblement
pour mettre d'accord à l'âge moyen des
et François Sauvade et comme ça voilà ça
sera rassemblement avec une troisième
personne au milieu vous le centriste qui
préférez-vous comme tête de liste Alain
jouantet
pour nous c'est d'abord le projet c'est
le programme c'est les idées pour la
Bourgogne et la Franche-Comté c'est une
plateforme de gouvernement local on va
appeler ça comme ça qui est la base en
fait de l'accord que nous souhaitons
conclure donc à ce stade moi j'échange
très cordialement avec un agent
voyandais j'échange très cordialement
avec François Sauvadet parce que on
n'est pas encore ce stade là de savoir
exactement quel est le programme des uns
et des autres et après quelle est la
place les uns et des autres donc
j'espère qu'on va y arriver le modem est
dans une logique de rassemblement et
fera tout pour y arriver si nous n'y
arrivons pas nous conduirons notre liste
autonome mais sans aucun problème mais
le modem est aussi dans une situation un
peu compliquée parce que alors vous vous
dites que vous cherchez l'alliance avec
l'UMP ou l'UDI et en même temps on voit
des modèles notamment en Bourgogne
notamment à Dijon qui gère des
collectivités avec les socialistes alors
ça risque d'être un petit peu compliqué
à comprendre pour les électeurs c'est
pas du tout compliqué en tout cas pour
nos fédérations j'ai réuni samedi à
Dijon les 8 départements nos fédérations
de vie départements on est tous sur la
même longueur d'onde donc il y a pas un
souci dans aucun des départements sur le
projet y compris les élus MoDem qui
siègent avec qui travaillent avec les
socialistes à Dijon voilà François de
seuil est président du du mois de Côte
d'Or et on est entièrement en phase sur
la logique qui est la nôtre pour les
élections régionales il a un mandat une
entente local pour sa ville de Dijon
c'est pas pour ça qu'il est menotté et
pas respecté il peut faire ce qu'il veut
il peut suivre notre logique pour la
Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui est une
logique de renouvellement et je
rappellerai accessoirement que voilà je
dirais il y a eu quand même un tir de
barrage de la part du Parti socialiste
contre le mouvement démocratique il y a
quelques années et que ça peut aussi
servir président
donc le tireur
ce qui est je veux dire chacun a voté à
son titre personnel comme il l'entendait
et donc aujourd'hui cette étape est
passée la logique maintenant aujourd'hui
c'est le rassemblement pour l'intérêt de
nos territoires
alors Maxime Thibault le dernier de nos
cinq invité qui a encore une fois
accepté notre invitation alors vous vous
êtes le benjamin a des têtes de liste de
votre de votre partie c'est une vraie
candidature je pense aussi est-ce que
c'est une vraie candidature ou est-ce
que vous aussi vous cherchez l'Union non
on cherche l'Union mais derrière de
nouvelles valeurs c'est à dire qu'on a
vu l'UMP et PS depuis 30 ans gerré nos
régions d'une manière catastrophique et
je pense qu'il faut rassembler les gens
autour de nouvelles personnes une
nouvelle génération politique et c'est
tout le combat que je suis en train de
mener aujourd'hui et j'ai des gens qui
viennent de l'UMP j'ai des gens qui
viennent du MoDem j'ai des gens qui
viennent de partout qui m'appellent
c'est que des rares fantastique
infantile pardon qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment Bourgogne
Franche-Comté nous intéresse pas
qu'est-ce que vous faites donc voilà on
invite les gens à se rassembler et on
mènera le combat jusqu'au bout avec un
projet et vous craignez pas
l'éparpillement des voies de droite
alors si maintenant on s'oriente vers
trois voire quatre listes et un risque
FN ou c'est par la gauche notre problème
on n'est pas là dans une logique ligne
droite on est dans une logique de
rassemblement autour d'un projet s'il y
a des gens qui viennent de la gauche qui
sont intéressés par notre projet ils
sont les bienvenus j'ai beaucoup de gens
qui soutenaient par le passé monsieur
Chevènement et qui aujourd'hui veulent
nous apporter leur soutien donc je suis
pas dans cette logique là moi je viens
de la droite c'est pas un secret mais je
pense aujourd'hui que la droite est très
mal représentée par Monsieur Sarkozy
sera très mal représenté à l'élection
présidentielle et qu'il est temps
d'avoir des gens qui incarnent les vrais
valeurs de la France qui sont celles
simplement de la sincérité déjà
Eric on va passer au bilan des demandes
à des présidents sortants je vais vous
relancer Christophe godler puisque vous
l'avez déjà évoqué vous disiez tout à
l'heure les régions les deux régions
sont en échec pourquoi vous tirez ce
bilan là et sur quoi vous appuyez pour
faire ce constatez je prends l'exemple
très concret de l'emploi
madame buffet lors de sa campagne 2010
où elle proposait de regarder les
Franc-Comtois droit dans les yeux
ben voilà je crois qu'aujourd'hui faut
plutôt regarder par terre la logique
d'avoir l'emploi en point numéro 1
totalement tombé à l'eau il y a eu 10%
de progression du chômage en 5 ans en
Bourgogne en Franche-Comté aujourd'hui
9-6 pour la pour la Franche-Comté et
neuf-2 pour la pour la Bourgogne donc on
a une situation de dégradation de
l'emploi alors on va dire que c'est
peut-être pas si grave que ça on est
encore en dessous de 10 sauf qu'il y a
des sous la moyenne national il y a des
équilibres total entre les régions
frontières de la Suisse on a des taux à
4,5 et des régions industrielles comme
en Saône-et-Loire ou dans les Rubens où
se trouve après 12 donc c'est un échec
du soutien à notre mission industriel
c'est un échec des politiques de
l'emploi alors que voilà clairement il y
avait un engagement ferme qui avait été
prise qui avait été pris à l'époque et
pour moi c'est une très grande déception
et il faut faire de l'économie la
priorité numéro 1 de la future grande
région Bourgogne Franche-Comté avec
l'équilibre des territoires qui pour moi
le deuxième point très fort à engager
dans le cadre de cette nouvelle Grande
Région un même constat vous à la région
reste quand même la plus industrielle de
France alors est-ce que c'est c'est un
succès des majorités sortantes ou est-ce
qu'au contraire c'est l'échec de ne pas
avoir su peut-être se renouveler écoutez
moi j'ai un principe c'est que je suis
un homme de projet d'entreprise j'ai
envie d'aller de l'avant
allez disons que chacun a ses théories
chacun à son action chacun a ses
résultats moi j'ai depuis 5 mois
travaillé sur un projet et puisque
Christophe Bruller parlait de l'emploi
moi je prends un engagement j'espère que
on aura tout à l'heure la possibilité
évidemment de revenir plus dans le
détail je prends un engagement c'est que
l'on arrive à faire baisser le chômage
en six ans sur Bourgogne Franche-Comté
de 10%. on a plus de 200 000 chômeurs
c'est je dirais le deuxième point fort
de mon projet avec le premier point qui
concerne la réussite de la fusion et le
troisième point qui est le rayonnement
par l'excellence ce deuxième ce deuxième
ambition c'est vraiment le développement
économique
il nous faudrait beaucoup de temps pour
y revenir dans le détail mais je suis
persuadé qu'au niveau de la région je
suis persuadé qu'au niveau de la région
avec les acteurs locaux avec toutes les
bonnes volontés on peut réussir ce que
nous ne pouvons pas faire au niveau de
l'État parce que souvent l'État est très
loin et en tout cas là où je suis
d'accord avec Christophe Grudler c'est
que la région c'est le développement
économique ce sont les entreprises c'est
l'emploi et moi ma priorité numéro un je
dirais que le futur président de la
Région s'il faisait que ça que ça
s'occuper des entreprises de l'emploi
des familles du bien-être des
Bourguignons et des Francs comptoirs et
qu'ils réussissent à faire baisser ce
chômage qui est le cancer de la société
je pense qu'il aurait réussi Maxime
Thiébault sur le bilan oui moi
j'aimerais rappeler qu'il y a quand même
25% des jeunes qui sont chômage
aujourd'hui c'est quand même un chiffre
qui est très important ce chômage il
vient de raison très simple c'est que
l'État a totalement abandonné la
politique économique en France aussi
bien sous le Parti socialiste que l'UMP
faut quand même savoir qu'on est dans
une terre qui est industrielle qui
exporte énormément et que l'eurofort que
l'on a connu pendant 10 ans a été
mortifère pour notre économie alors en
ce moment on connaît par la Banque
centrale européenne une petite baisse de
l'euro qui permet de relancer la machine
mais le mâle a été fait pendant de
nombreuses années je pense que ça va pas
être facile à récupérer et c'est tout la
raison de mon engagement c'est à dire
que je vois que depuis 30 ans les
chèques existent et qu'à un moment il
faut faire quelque chose d'autre c'est
si le prix de mon l'a dit tout à l'heure
j'avais mis en parler vous assumez le
bilan à vous l'avez dit vous-même
qu'est-ce qui a été positif ou négatif
selon vous dans ces dernières mandatures
un bon avis il y a une grande réussite
au niveau de la mandature précédente en
tout cas en Franche-Comté c'est sur
l'efficacité énergétique et notamment la
mise en place enfin la continuité des
philosophies c'est un programme de
rénovation des bâtiments et par contre
pour nous l'échec il est plus sur les
enfin sur tout ce qui a été fait au
niveau agricole parce qu'on encourage
vraiment les circuits courts
l'agriculture bio et il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire et voilà c'est loin voilà
exactement excusez-moi mais et
phillologie effectivement la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments s'est affiché
comme un étendard notamment en
Franche-Comté mais on n'en voit pas la
couleur des emplois verts si vous
permettez
on connaît la situation du bâtiment des
entreprises du bâtiment non mais rénover
changement c'est un emploi temps plein
pendant six mois si on renouvelle les 30
000 logements qu'on a annoncé c'est
15000 emplois de créer oui mais c'est
une c'est une annonce non mais
c'est pas une annonce puisqu'on commence
à le faire alors justement
qu'est-ce que vous vous avez à
avec le micro ce sera mieux le problème
du chômage c'est un échec collectif je
pense que ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
que du temps de l'équipe précédente au
niveau national le chômage était là que
le chômage est toujours là et que c'est
un peu facile de dire que c'est un échec
dont la Franche-Comté seule est
responsable par ailleurs moi je suis
adepte de la vérité en politique vous
avez dit que vous aussi vous étiez
adepte de la vérité et la vérité vous le
savez c'est qu'aujourd'hui la croissance
même si elle revient ne crée pas
d'emploi on est dans un système
économique aujourd'hui où la croissance
n'est pas porteuse d'emploi il faut donc
basculer dans un nouveau modèle dans un
nouveau système alors ce que nous avons
fait en Franche-Comté se voit quand même
parce que vous parlez des voies
d'excellence nous avons pris le parti de
travailler sur les métiers d'avenir sur
ce qui fait l'excellence de cette région
que ça soit sur l'énergie sur la santé
sur les micromécaniques entablant sur la
recherche nous avons eu un engagement au
niveau de la recherche exceptionnelle
que nous avons tenu tout au long du
bilan parce que derrière la recherche
derrière le travail des laboratoire ce
sont des processus nouveaux des
matériaux nouveaux qui s'invente et ce
sont les métiers de demain et c'est
là-dessus que nous devons travailler
nous avons par ailleurs travaillé sur
les emplois que nous avons nous
maintenus notamment beaucoup en milieu
rural ces emplois de l'économie sociale
ces emplois d'aide à domicile où nous
avons mis en place une politique
publique pour que ces emplois ne
disparaissent pas alors qu'ils sont
essentiels qu'ils rendent des services
humains absolument important et nous
avons mis en place une politique public
de l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
est active et enfin et moi je le
revendique nous avons effectivement à
protéger tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
traversent cette situation extrêmement
difficile nous avons été les premiers en
région de Franche-Comté à mettre en
place les bases de ce qu'on appelle la
sécurité sociale professionnelle qui
consistait quand la crise est apparue
quand la crise est tombée que les
entreprises n'avaient plus de cahier de
commande on a fait en sorte que ces
entreprises puissent garder les salariés
et qu'on puisse tous états région et
autres organismes financés le maintien
de ses salariés dans les entreprises ça
s'appelait former plutôt que chômés et
depuis nous n'avons pas arrêté de mettre
en place des processus alors je suis
d'accord le chômage est là et c'est
vraiment un fléau numéro 1 et c'est pour
cela que tous mes efforts sont consacrés
à cette question et que la priorité du
mandat elle a été le développement
symbolique parce qu'à côté des emplois
que nous perdons il y a aussi des
emplois qui se créent vous aurez
l'occasion de répondre peut-être dans le
thème de l'économie là on voudrait
parler quand même de la fusion parce que
il y a les Francs courtois il y a aussi
les Bourguignons puisqu'on sera donc un
conseil régional Bourgogne Franche-Comté
les préfets de Bourgogne Franche-Comté
eux ont rendu leur rapport à au Premier
ministre sur la réorganisation des
services de l'état des deux régions
c'est un rapport qui prône un peu
l'équilibre entre Dijon et Besançon
entre la Bourgogne et la Franche-Comté
vous aussi vous êtes aussi dans le
consensuel les uns et les autres pour
que l'équilibre soit bien respecté au
niveau du conseil régional
écoutez l'équilibre il est indispensable
parce que s'il n'y a pas d'équilibre on
ne sera pas dans une dans une fusion
association mais on sera dans une fusion
absorption je pense que aussi bien pour
les Bourguignons que pour les
francs-combois il faut que cette fusion
soit équilibrée d'autant plus que cette
fusion bon les socialistes l'ont décidé
ils nous ont pas demandé notre avis mais
moi je l'ai voté finalement parce que
pas toujours dire qu'il faut des
réformes et que à chaque fois qu'on nous
en présente une on dise bah c'est pas la
bonne c'est la suivante qui sera la
bonne donc moi j'ai pris mes
responsabilités j'ai dit cette fusion je
vais la voter et moi j'ai envie de m'en
occuper parce que je me sens
complètement investi dans cette affaire
et donc sur votre question de
l'équilibre je vois pas où est
l'équilibre pour l'instant dans ce qui
est proposé par le gouvernement je
cherche l'équilibre mais je ne le trouve
pas pour moi il y a deux grandes
institutions aujourd'hui il y a
évidemment les services de l'État dans
les deux régions et puis il y a les
services du conseil régional dans les
deux régions donc pour moi l'équilibre
ça voudrait dire que tout ça doit pas
être dans la même ville sinon au départ
il y a déjà pas d'équilibre et ensuite
vous êtes donc le conseil régional son
siège soit à Besançon c'est ça moi je ne
donne pas les noms des villes je ne
donne pas les noms des villes mais je
dis non pas forcément et je ne donne pas
le nom des villes je dis est-ce qu'on
veut vraiment un équilibre ou est-ce
qu'on ou est-ce qu'on est en train de
nous déguiser quelque chose qui n'est
pas du tout équilibré autre point
d'équilibre qui pour moi est
particulièrement important c'est
l'accroche sur les 8 départements parce
que comme on est dans une fusion
administrative il faut bien que ceux qui
nous écoutent comprennent que on va pas
créer un Bourguignon franc-comtois ou un
franco-bourguignon chacun va garder son
identité qu'est-ce que c'est l'idée de
la fusion c'est on fusionne donc on
dégage des moyens et en dégageant des
moyens du coup on soutient les projets
dans tous les territoires donc il faut
que le futur conseil régional il faut
que le futur État en région soit
accroché dans chacun des départements
c'est pourquoi je propose que dans
chacun des départements nous passions
des conventions avec les conseils
départementaux qui viennent d'être élus
pour que systématiquement les services
de l'État les services de la Région
soient présents dans ces départements
pour nos concitoyens mais aussi pour les
entreprises si on fait tout ça alors on
aura vraiment une fusion équilibrée
Christophe griller vous qui êtes élu
d'un département périphérique le
Territoire de Belfort on sait que le
territoire s'est posé la question de
savoir si c'était pas mieux de regarder
vers l'Alsace plutôt que vers la
Bourgogne Franche-Comté quels sont les
ingrédients pour réussir cette fusion
selon vous il y a pas que le Territoire
de Belfort qui a la marge dire de la
grande région c'est le grande région
c'est deux régions qui travaillent
ensemble Besançon n'avait jamais été
reconnu comme la capitale de toute la
Franche-Comté Dijon n'a jamais été
Bourgogne parce qu'il y a plein de
territoires périphériques qui
travaillent avec les autres donc pour
moi la condition de la réussite c'est
que chacun des territoires soient
respectés et c'est même plus important
que de savoir si la capitale est à
Besançon ou Dijon il y a 85 % de la
population qui est hors de ces grandes
agglomérations pour vous pour moi c'est
pas le essentiel le débat c'est comment
on garantit l'équilibre comment on
permet aux gens de l'Yonne de continuer
à travailler avec les régions
parisiennes aux gens de la Nièvre de
travailler avec la région Centre aux
gens de Saône-et-Loire de travailler
avec ronalpes et aux belfortain enfin
l'air urbaine de formulaire de
travailler avec l'Alsace ou avec la
Suisse comme une partie du loup là vous
posez la question c'est quoi la réponse
selon la réponse c'est qu'il faut il
faut que le que la capital régionale ne
soit pas l'ogre qui mange les petits
mais que ça soit le grand frère qui tend
la main à tous ces territoires qui
doivent pouvoir vivre en autonomie en
autonomie avec le soutien bienveillant
de la région avec des services régionaux
présents dans ces départements dans ces
entités dans ces bassins de vie
certainement c'est une bonne idée avec
les conseils départementaux parce que
une direction de l'éducation commune
dans dans une ville qui permet de
traiter à la fois les collèges pour les
départements et les lycées pour les
régions peut-être que ça c'est une
synergie intelligente qui paiera
peut-être d'économiser quelques moyens
Marie tu fais un mot prenez votre micro
un le micro le micro périphériques
je vous parle trop pour monopoliser la
parole à ce moment-là mais sur la
question des territoires périphériques
ce qu'il faut c'est absolument renforcer
les coopérations inter régionales et ça
je l'ai toujours dit depuis le début
jusqu'à maintenant il n'y a pas eu assez
de coopération interne régionale et
demain mais à la fois
tout à fait mais je pense qu'il faut
renforcer les coopérations avec ronalpes
renforcer les coopérations avec les Pays
de Loire et avec vous de France pour que
effectivement les territoires qui sont
effectivement aux marges de cette région
si retrouvent parce qu'il n'est pas
question que les flux
d'affaires de circulation de transport
de d'activité qu'il y a entre ces
territoires et le territoire juste à
côté
s'interrompre ça n'a aucun sens donc il
faut véritablement que nous renfortions
par exemple pour voir comment au niveau
des transports entre Franche-Comté
Bourgogne entre Franche-Comté Bourgogne
et Rhône-Alpes les chances puissent
effectivement être encore plus fluide
à l'Elysée il faut quand même le
rappeler et finalement on se retrouve à
se poser des questions sur un hôtel par
les assemblées par les assemblées UMPS
il faut le rappeler avec une seule vous
avez finalement
été contre parce qu'il juge que la
démocratie s'exerce dans le cadre de la
proximité c'est-à-dire au plus près des
peuples mais
vous l'avez dit elle a été votée
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait et
comment on fait pour que tout le monde
on va essayer de faire du mieux qu'on
peut avec cette fusion qui a été fait et
pas préparée malheureusement donc moi je
pense que pour les hôtels de Région il
faut donner la parole au peuple on a le
cadre du référendum on a quand même
donné on a qu'à l'utiliser et on verra
ce qu'on diront les gens et en évitant
parce que c'est ce qui risque d'arriver
de mettre les Franc-Comtois contre les
Bourguignons et je pense qu'on peut être
étonné par la réponse je sais pas quel
sera mais les gens sont tellement
tellement dégoûtés de voir ces petits
débats de politiciens alors qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux bouts
que on ferait mieux de vite classer
l'affaire on va avoir aussi le problème
des hôtels de Région qui vont être
obligés d'être refait ça va coûter un
fric monstre comment on va faire cet
argent là va être encore gaspiller mais
prenez votre micro
il faut il faut pas dire des choses
comme ça parce qu'on attise les peurs et
les inquiétez pas
c'est l'hôtel de région que l'hôtel de
région soit à Dijon ou à Besançon
celui qui restera on aura besoin de lui
de toute façon parce qu'il y a des
services qui demeureront pas déménager
le deuxième on en fait quoi tous les
services ne vont pas déménager dans un
lieu unique on va faire du 2e hôtel de
région ils gardera des services bien
évidemment et c'est ça et c'est ça
l'équilibre dont on parle aujourd'hui
alors vous dites l'équilibre il est pas
au rendez-vous on est en train de le
travailler la loi vient d'être
promulguée le décret
concernant le chef-lieu qui a juste
d'être signé par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui est quand même
responsable de tout cela dit lui-même
qu'il faut arriver à un équilibre entre
les fonctions stratégiques entre deux
villes notamment quand elles sont
proches comme Dijon et Besançon on
devrait être en ordre
de combat on devrait être en ordre de
combat on va perdre un an sur des petits
débats à savoir comment on va exercer
les pouvoirs et pas des petits débats on
est en train de réorganiser les
institutions de la France pour les 20
prochaines années c'est pas des petits
débats j'aimerais qu'on entende s'il
vous plaît j'aimerais qu'on entende
Cécile prud'hommes qui sait pas exprimé
sur sur cette question sur les
ingrédients de la fusion il y a quatre
francs cantons et un Bourguignon autour
de la table on a l'impression de cliquer
le débat de la fusion a commencé que les
Francs courtois n'ont qu'une trouille
c'est de se faire manger par les
Bourguignons comment vous la bisontine
vous analysez ça est-ce que
moi je me définis comme pour qui
comtoise pour le coup donc je la fusion
des régions ça me fait pas peur mais je
pense qu'il faudra veiller à pas oublier
les territoires ruraux et pour nous le
développement enfin ne pas oublier le
territoire euro ça passe par un
développement du numérique
et le développement du numérique il
permettra aussi de redéfinir des
conditions de travail de désenclaver le
territoire et effectivement il faut
travailler en coopération et pas réduire
le débat à Dijon Besançon les pensées la
région dans sa totalité alors vous avez
synthèse Jean-Michel on n'a pas dit
qu'on avait peur de la Bourgogne moi je
parle des clips des territoires c'est
aussi valable
c'est le terme que vous avez employé je
parle de l'Aude que la capitale soit
Besançon ou à Dijon c'est pareil il faut
pas que la capitale régionale soit la le
lieu qui donne un diktat pour toute une
région composite qui ne reconnaît pas
cette région comme un bassin de vie
unique donc il faut que les gens
travaillent avec avec les autres régions
mais le problème c'est le respect et
vous m'inquiétez madame lui fait quand
vous me dites il faut renforcer les
coopérations avec les autres régions
c'est pas ça le problème le problème
c'est que la région de demain elle doit
respecter ses territoires elle doit pas
les considérer comme des sujets
exclusivement
périphérique monsieur en vous disant
qu'effectivement par rapport au
territoire de l'Yonne au territoire d'un
hivernais au territoire de l'air urbaine
il faut absolument que les coopérations
avec les régions voisines soient
renforcées mais sur le reste une des
clés de réussite de cette grande région
c'est effectivement la
territorialisation des politiques
publiques et moi je dis tout le temps
que la grande région elle s'accompagnera
d'une déconcentration qui nous oblige à
nous organiser à partir des territoires
allez si vous nous rejoignez vous êtes
bien sur France 3 Bourgogne et France 3
Franche-Comté on est à Besançon pour une
émission spéciale à un peu plus de six
mois des élections régionales et on
reçoit quelques-uns des candidats à la
présidence de cette future grande région
Bourgogne Franche-Comté et Mesdames
Messieurs vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure Maxime Thiébaut vous disiez on
sait pas pourquoi on se présente à
priori quand même le gouvernement
souhaite que les futurs grandes régions
est une compétence majeure c'est le
développement économique donc on
voudrait vous interroger là-dessus sur
vos projets en matière de développement
économique vous avez quasiment tous
parler du chômage en début d'émission
Alain je voyandais vous vous disiez vous
souhaitez prendre des engagements
chiffrés mais est-ce que vous en aurez
les moyens
d'abord notre projet n'est pas terminé
puisque nous sommes en train de
continuer les consultations mais il
s'organise autour de trois ambitions une
première ambition sur la réussite de la
fusion j'y reviens pas on vient d'en
parler maintenant un deuxième grand
ambition justement sur
la relance de l'attractivité économique
de notre de notre région moi je veux pas
aller trop sur le bilan des socialistes
bon voilà il est pas bon il est pas bon
il s'est passé
sur l'économie qui est notre deuxième
grande ambition et puis notre troisième
grande ambition c'est le rayonnement par
l'excellence c'est-à-dire la culture
notre patrimoine tout ce qui permet à
cette nouvelle région de d'être fier et
de faire parler d'elle alors pour
revenir au développement économique très
concrètement on a un peu plus de 200 000
chômeurs en Bourgogne Franche-Comté
aujourd'hui ce qui est beaucoup et ce
qui est beaucoup trop on a 35000 jeunes
de moins de 25 ans qui sont également au
chômage moi je crois qu'il faut changer
complètement
l'esprit de la politique économique
actuelle d'abord sur un milliard 300
millions d'euros de budget global
Bourgogne Franche-Comté on a un peu plus
de 100 millions d'euros seulement en
véritable crédit d'intervention sur
l'économie de la région c'est nettement
insuffisant la région doit se concentrer
sur ce qui est sa préoccupation
principale c'est le développement
économique je précise à l'injoignant des
aujourd'hui le développement économique
c'est un peu plus de 5% du budget en
Franche-Comté et un peu plus de 9%
quasiment 10% en Bourgogne d'accord et
on voit bien d'ailleurs que sur plein de
critères il y a un déséquilibre entre la
Franche-Comté et la Bourgogne d'ailleurs
la loi n'a rien prévu ce qui me conduit
à déposer une proposition de loi puisque
l'Ariane la loi n'a rien prévu sur un
système progressif pour mettre les deux
régions au même niveau peut-être qu'on
aura l'occasion d'en parler mais c'est
pas votre question mais c'est pas votre
c'est pas votre question sur le
développement économique je pense qu'il
y a plusieurs ingrédients deux ou trois
concrets concrets il me semble que Pôle
emploi
doit revenir disons indirectement dans
le giron de la région c'est très
important on sait qu'avec
l'expérimentation on a le droit de le
faire moi si je suis président de la
région je solliciterai le gouvernement
pour que ce soit la région qui soit le
coordonnateur des politiques publiques
en direction du retour à l'emploi la
région dispose des crédits de la
formation nous avons la possibilité du
soutien aux filières et la
réorganisation aussi des différentes
politiques en direction des entreprises
concrètement actuellement Bourgogne
Franche-Comté 47 politiques différentes
en direction des entreprises 47 10 font
différents la gestion de cette de ce
truc qui est absolument incompréhensible
rien que ça c'est 5 millions d'euros par
an et je souhaite qu'on puisse
économiser beaucoup plus en réduisant
les frais de fonctionnement des deux
régions s'il faut rentrer dans le détail
je suis prêt à le faire pour qu'on
remette de l'argent beaucoup plus sur
les filières sur les clusters sur le
soutien aux entreprises sur l'emploi et
l'accompagnement
auprès de auprès des demandeurs d'emploi
on n'a pas assez on n'a pas assez de
personnes pour s'occuper des chômeurs
donc peut-être qu'on y reviendra tout à
l'heure je pense que si on fait tout ça
l'engagement de faire baisser 10%
c'est-à-dire de faire 20 000
travailleurs supplémentaires et de faire
entrer 5000 jeunes avec des emplois
énergies sur lesquels j'ai déjà beaucoup
réfléchi je sais ce qu'il faut faire
mais je veux pas être trop longue ça
veut dire 25000 emplois sur 6 ans et je
pense que c'est concrètement tout à fait
possible à faire avec toutes les bonnes
monsieur Joyandet vous avez été ministre
donc vous avez quand même une conception
haute des responsabilités et vous savez
que vous ne pouvez pas
évaluer l'action de la région uniquement
en fonction de son budget d'intervention
économique sur l'emploi vous le savez
bien quand on met en place un plan de
relance du bâtiment quand on lance des
travaux sur les gares sur les rails
quand on lance des travaux extrêmement
importants sur la rénovation des lycées
on contribue à l'emploi donc c'est pas
le seul chiffre du budget qui doit
effectivement vous mobiliser par
ailleurs je vous dirai sur ce que vous
venez de dire par rapport à Pôle emploi
c'est la revendication des régions c'est
ce que nous ne cessons de demander au
gouvernement effectivement que nous
ayons la responsabilité de coordonner
l'action de Pôle Emploi juste 30
secondes juste 30 secondes tout à
l'heure vous parliez des politiques
inter régionales que vous n'aviez pas su
mettre en place vous avez dit oui c'est
notre faute il y a que des présidents
socialistes dans les régions que
n'avez-vous pas fait mais
vous avez un gouvernement socialiste
vous avez des cadres socialistes partout
vous avez une région socialiste une
deuxième région socialiste si
départements sur 8 depuis 10 ans
socialiste et aujourd'hui vous venez
nous expliquer ce que vous n'avez pas
faire moi je n'osais pas le dire
j'essaie juste d'expliquer ce que je
ferai si je suis président de la région
de candidats je voudrais simplement
rapidement dire que nous avons construit
nos politiques d'intervention sur les
filières sur les clusters sur la
recherche sur l'innovation avec les
partenaires économiques que nous avons
une convention avec la Chambre de
commerce régionale qui est en vie et de
toutes les chambres de commerce de
France donc parce que nous avons parce
que nous avons un partenariat avec le
monde économique très fort et nous avons
loué un partenariat avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux pour déterminer ces
politiques de protection et de
sécurisation professionnelle vis-à-vis
de ceux qui sont victimes du chômage
donc quand je vous entends dire c'est
l'échec c'est la catastrophe je ferais
mieux mais écoutez on souhaite toujours
de faire le maximum mais nous avons pris
les moyens de bâtir ces politiques qui
sont des politiques sensibles pas tout
seul nous n'avons pas fait des
politiques d'intervention économique
tout seul dans notre coin entre élus
nous avons travaillé cela avec
l'ensemble des corps intermédiaires
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux et
l'ensemble des représentants du monde
patronal
Maxime
que votre premier objectif c'est de de
chercher des économies en chassant les
dépenses futiles si je vous ai bien lu
et c'est quoi c'est quoi une dépense
futile aujourd'hui
excusez-moi de vous interrompre mais la
chance
je voudrais quand même oui juste en
introduction est-ce que vous allez dire
que la Chambre nationale des comptes par
la Cour des comptes la Cour nationale
des comptes
délivrer un satisfaitiste total à la
région de Franche-Comté on la citant en
exemple des collectivités qui ont su ne
pas gaspiller l'argent public en se
concentrant
alors moi je viens aussi
c'est la création d'une association par
Monsieur patria une subvention 400 000
euros qui lui servait ensuite de voyager
à l'international en dehors de tout
contrôle des conseillers régionaux voilà
ça c'est une dépense fictive mais moi je
voudrais revenir sur l'économie parce
que depuis tout à l'heure on entend
parler d'emploi emploi le vrai emploi
durable aujourd'hui c'est l'industrie et
l'industrie elle est plus là moi je ne
vois aucune solution dans ce que vous
dites pour régler le problème de
l'industrie les solutions elles sont
nationale elles sont avec l'État et
ramener la pouvoir le pouvoir
parce que je vais pouvoir dire attention
où est le conseiller régional ou est le
président du conseil régional quand on
va qu'un marché public est attribué aux
Américains sur les voitures de l'armée
française au lieu d'être attribué
beaucoup fait parler en entreprise
madame mais votre partie avec l'UMP ont
voté l'interdiction du protectionnisme
en France l'interdiction d'aider les
sociétés françaises oui c'est marqué
dans le traité du fonctionnement de
l'Union européenne faut pas l'oublier de
souverainiste
le gaullisme savoir une certaine idée de
la France s'y tenir et aider les
entreprises à aller jusqu'à l'engagement
internationaux mais les engagements
internationaux s'ils sont pas pris
légitimement parce que le dernier
engagement international qu'on a pris
cette traité de Lisbonne qui est venu
trahir le référendum constitutionnel de
2005 où les Français avaient dit non
donc ils ont aucune légitimité les
accords internationaux alors et toute la
question là où je veux en venir sur
l'emploi sur l'emploi je ce qu'il faut
déjà faire un état des lieux des
problèmes qu'on a eu en Bourgogne
Franche-Comté et d'intervenir au niveau
de l'État pour que les normes soient
prises voilà c'est tout là on a on va
avoir un désastre avec Alstom on a Areva
on a quand même Areva qui est en pleine
crise on a des rachats par des sociétés
étrangères de nos industries on ne se
rend même pas compte que quand même y
existent une guerre économique mondiale
que les délocalisations ne sont pas loin
et on voit rien on entend parler qu'il
faut ramener Pôle emploi au niveau des
régions
à côté de vous à côté de vous vous avez
vous avez parlé du marché attribué il y
a quelques jours maintenant pour la par
l'armée française qui va acheter des
véhicules tout terrain un constructeur
américain ça a beaucoup fait causer
notamment en Franche-Comté et à côté de
vous vous avez un élu qui a lancé une
pétition contre cette décision c'est
Christophe gruddler encore une fois je
répète vous êtes belfortun donc voilà
c'est à quelques kilomètres Belfort de
l'usine PSA de Sochaux donc je vous
invite à signer la pétition qui est
toujours en ligne donc n'hésitez pas
des emplois effectivement Bourgogne
Franche-Comté sont des emplois
industriels c'est la région la plus
industrielle de France comment maintenir
ses emplois
17,3% des Anglais déjà 30 secondes sur
la pétition c'est un scandale que le
gouvernement que soutient madame du fait
comment des Ford
américaines pour remplacer des des
Peugeot P4 dans une région industrielle
madame Dufay où est-ce que vous entendez
vous indigniez est-ce que vous vous êtes
est-ce que vous êtes indignés quand le
gouvernement a commandé des véhicules
américains à la place de véhicules
français vous n'avez rien dit mais vous
avez laissé faire monsieur Macron à ce
jour
la pétition j'ai lancé et tu as plus de
17000 signatures plus de 17000
signatures je vais les remettre à
Monsieur Valls à la fin du mois pour qui
nous explique comment demain il va
associer les industriels français au
choix de l'armée française parce que
effectivement le traité de
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
mais il y a l'article 346 qui dit que
sur les marchés protégés de l'armée il y
a des préférences nationales qui sont
jamais s'entendre
et ça c'est de la compétence du conseil
régional lors du mal à m'exprimer
donc très simplement un homme du fait
l'emploi c'est pas que les emplois de
demain c'est aussi les emplois
industriels les emplois d'aujourd'hui
qu'il faut pérenniser alors vous êtes là
dans la prospective sur l'emploi de
demain je suis désolé on a un tissu
industriel extrêmement important qu'il
faut soutenir la filière automobile la
filière transport en général avec le
ferroviaire avec également
l'aéronautique je vous rappelle que
l'aéronautique moi j'avais souhaité
qu'on est un cluster aéronautique dans
dans les ruban Belfort Montbéliard les
grands nautiques c'est 10000 employés
aujourd'hui en Bourgogne Franche-Comté
c'est une filière à structurer au niveau
Bourgogne Franche-Comté pour développer
demain de l'emploi c'est le soutien la
grande alimentaire c'est le soutien
l'artisanat au commerce je veux dire le
soutien comment il faut soutenir les
entreprises comme elles sont beaucoup
soutenues par le gouvernement
c'est une mise en réseau c'est une mise
en réseau avec milliards de
et autres si vous me permettez les
protéger j'ai du mal à développer un
raisonnement c'est assez terrible donc
après on va dire des phrases jetées
comme ça donc si vous me permettez les
le soutien ça se structure ça se
structure au niveau de cette grande
région et ça sera pas également de
l'identité pour dire que dans cette
région et ben aussi on est une des
capitales de mondial de l'énergie c'est
la région de Franche-Comté parce qu'on a
des entreprises un peu partout sur le
ferroviaire sur l'aérotique on doit
pouvoir développer une politique d'image
qui nous permet d'obtenir des marchés et
une politique de soutien financier
évidemment c'est possible d'avance c'est
pas avec les 23 millions par exemple que
que la région Franche-Comté cette année
au soutien économique au développement
économique sur 216 millions de budgets
qu'on va arriver a vraiment soutenir
industriels
sur l'économie important et il y a de
très bons créneaux en difficulté
diversification notamment dans le
tourisme c'est SIM freedom alors en
technologie l'hiver il y a un coup de
vent là tout d'un coup c'est Europe éc
souhaite une éco-région on entend déjà
ça depuis très longtemps vous êtes
associés avec les verres depuis avec le
Parti socialiste depuis de longues
années au conseil général ça veut dire
quoi une écho région concrètement par
rapport à ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
il y a plein plein de métiers à
développer dans les énergies
renouvelables dans si on applique la
transition écologique jusqu'au bout et
c'est une urgence vu l'urgence
climatique de le faire vraiment et à
fond donc il y a tous les métiers de
l'énergie renouvelable on parlait d'un
réveil à 5 minutes par exemple enfin
nous on est contre le nucléaire et on
pense que la filière du nucléaire qui
est présente dans la vallée de l'énergie
et à Valduc va falloir envisager sa
reconversion et plutôt investir sur la
formation professionnelle mais dans le
domaine du démantèlement du nucléaire et
ça aussi c'est des métiers est-ce que
démonte les nucléaire en France il y en
a pour 15 ans minimum mais la filière
s'occupe d'ailleurs de ça maintenant du
nucléaire en Allemagne la réouverture
des centrales charbon et la pollution
qu'on connaît
produire de l'énergie produire de
l'énergie par rapport de l'énergie enfin
produire de l'énergie en utilisant les
énergies renouvelables ça crée trois
fois plus d'emplois que produire de
l'énergie par rapport que avec du
nucléaire moi je parle des conséquences
oui l'ADEB a dit
qu'on pouvait produire suffisamment
d'énergie d'énergie pour tout le monde
d'ici 2050
sans nucléaire et sans charbon alors un
sujet que qui a semé beaucoup de
discorde notamment entre les Verts et le
parti socialistes se sont les aéroports
pour des raisons historiques en raison
de la présence militaire notamment Dijon
a un aéroport aujourd'hui qui réduit à
la portion congrue alors qu'il est
énormément d'investissement beaucoup
d'investissements aussi à Dole à une
demi-heure de Dijon alors quel est un
peu votre position vous avez madame dû
faire récemment dire STOP à toutes les
subventions c'est ça du concert régional
vous n'êtes plus pour un aéroport
régional j'ai toujours dit qu'un
aéroport régional devait être un lieu
d'où les gens partent et où d'autres
arrivent pour venir
explorer notre notre région dépensée
contribuer au tourisme et il se devait
être gagnant-gagnant aujourd'hui
l'impact économique est limité
aujourd'hui l'organisation économique
qui a été choisie pour doltaveau c'est
une organisation qui fait partir les
gens moi je suis heureuse que les
Franc-Comtois et les Bourguignons
puissent aller facilement depuis Dole à
Marrakech à Bastia ou à Nice mais
effectivement ça ne ramène rien d'un
point de vue économique à la
Franche-Comté donc il faut absolument
étudier un autre modèle économique et
aujourd'hui
ce qu'on avait étudié ce cela
qui n'était pas du du low cost mais je
pense qu'entre Dijon et Besançon il y
aurait dû peut-être à un moment y avoir
une coopération qui n'a pas existé et
moi je pense que ce sujet il est vivant
et qu'il faut l'étudier mais quels sont
les conditions de faisabilité
économique d'un aéroport pour notre
région sachant qu'on a quand même une
desserte ferroviaire qui est très
importante c'est si le Prudhomme il faut
étudier alors un aéroport
aujourd'hui tout le monde dit qu'il y a
pas d'argent on va pas pouvoir investir
surtout donc nous Europe Écologie Les
Verts on dit qu'il faut faire des choix
que les choix on veut les faire sur le
faire le TER et aider par exemple les
zones Morvan etc à se développer aussi
par le TER plutôt qu'un continuer à
investir continuer à mettre de l'argent
public pour financer à 35 millions déjà
qui finalement sert pas à grand chose à
part avoir des départs en on n'est pas
pour que les gens partent pas en
vacances mais il y a trois aéroports
internationaux à moins d'une heure balle
Saint-Exupéry Orly Lyon exactement donc
c'est pas la priorité non pas du tout
joyeux sur le sujet aéroport bon moi
j'étais assez triste de voir que la
région Franche-Comté a léger pour ne pas
dire arrêtait en tout cas dans l'esprit
ce soutien à l'aéroport de Tavaux c'est
franchement au moment où on fusionne
Bourgogne Franche-Comté où on veut on a
un peu d'ambition même si on gère bien
les crédits de la région je vois pas
comment une région comme Bourgoin
Franche-Comté ne pourrait pas avoir un
aéroport une digne de ce nom mais pose
subventionner Alain joignant les
vacances de quelques-uns par de l'argent
public donc l'argent de tout le monde
la SNC est-ce qu'on est-ce pardon est-ce
que l'on subventionne la SNCF la réponse
est oui est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on a des
routes publiées au niveau est-ce qu'un
aéroport international est-ce qu'un
aéroport international subventionné
pas nécessaire dans une région moderne
la réponse est oui je voulais juste sur
le projet si vous le permettez juste
quelques minutes je pense quand même que
si on veut redonner du crédit à la
classe politique notamment sur une
élection comme l'élection régionale il
faut quand même que les projets soient
concrets soit chiffrés moi c'est ce que
je c'est ce que j'essaie de faire sur
tous les sujets sur lesquels vous
m'interrogez ce contenter de généralité
comme je les entends vous vous remettez
de l'argent public vous êtes élu vous
remettez et à Dole et mais plus à Dijon
bien sûr je fais un choix je dis que
Dole tient la corde c'est c'est des
observateurs sont assez d'accord
là-dessus ça fait partie d'ailleurs d'un
ensemble de choses sur la fusion sur la
fusion équilibrée ou est-ce qu'on met la
préfecture de région où est-ce qu'on met
le conseil régional où est-ce qu'on met
l'aéroport et comment on organise tout
ça juste dire une chose parce que tout à
l'heure madame du fait disait on peut
pas décréter que etc moi je n'ai pas
beaucoup critiqué ce que vous avez fait
je pense que vous l'avez noté pendant
cette émission je demande juste du
crédit sur le travail sérieux que nous
faisons pour chiffrer
financer le projet quand j'ai pris en
deux secondes quand j'ai pris la quand
j'ai pris très vite très vite quand j'ai
repris la ville de Vesoul avec mon
équipe quand on a pris la ville de
Vesoul le socialiste on a dit on fera
500 emplois 500 logements on baissera
les impôts tous les ans on a fait 500
emplois on a fait 500 logements on a
baissé les impôts tous les gens dans
tous les gens et je veux dire que pour
la région il faut absolument avoir des
projets chiffré c'est comme ça que nos
concitoyens reviendront vers nous qui
nous referont confiance et qui n'iront
plus vers les extrêmes donc je suis à
300 % d'accord avec adjoignantais sur ce
dossier
une région qui tient la route et là
forcément un aéroport qui doit plutôt
être basé à doltaveau effectivement il
s'agit pas de faire un hub international
il y a effectivement des choses à Lyon à
Bâle-Mulhouse pas loin voir à Paris de
l'autre côté
un équipement dans un premier temps bien
évidemment mais sur le même modèle
économique aujourd'hui
atteint son seuil de développement parce
que est un outil de développement on
sait que les infrastructures en général
permettent de générer du développement
la Bourgogne Franche-Comté c'est l'avant
dernier PIB de France c'est une des
régions les plus pauvres de quel droit
on offrait une sous-région qui
dépendrait d'un aéroport d'autres
régions qui dépendrait de plein de
choses dans d'autres régions c'est
absolument pas possible à tous les gens
qui dénonçaient les aéroports et
notamment suite dolta
ventes
attendez moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est ce qu'elle a dénoncé la tour de la
Cour des comptes pour moi c'est plus la
compétition entre Dijon et deltaveau qui
fait qu'il y a eu un gaspillage de fonds
publics énorme
parce qu'il y avait il y avait une
compétition à ce niveau-là et demain si
on a la chance d'avoir un aéroport on
doit pouvoir faire venir des gens en
pour une Franche-Comté par le tourisme
on doit pour aller survenir sur
l'économie développement économique
dénoncer les dépenses futiles alors j'en
étais pas il faut pas tout confondre
c'est-à-dire il y a des dépenses de
fonctionnement qui sont hyper futiles
mais je pense que l'aéroport est
important et il faut l'associer à la
question du tourisme c'est-à-dire que ce
sera notre travail de régionaux que de
pouvoir développer des axes autour de
cette aéroport la Cour des comptes elle
compare Lyon et Dole c'est comparer
l'éléphant et la souris excusez-moi
c'est possible pour faire venir en avion
des touristes aujourd'hui
et ça ne fonctionne pas on ne sait pas
lire des touristes alors le principal
défaut de ces grandes régions c'est
qu'elles sont grandes leurs principales
qualités c'est qu'elles pourront aller
peut-être à l'international et aller
chercher les touristes on fait plus
boulot de VRP et il faudrait peut-être
le faire et moi la seule chose qui me
dérange énormément à Dole c'est le low
cost c'est à dire Ryanair qui ne
respecte pas
de service public vous refondez vous le
ressentez sur du non low cost et Dijon
ça n'a pas marché non plus alors qu'à
Dijon on a quand même une zone de
chalandise extrêmement importante mais
donc il y a quand même une vraie
question qui se pose à ton effectivement
la capacité à faire vivre un aéroport
régional moi je dis qu'il faut étudier
cette question je ne suis pas sûr de ce
serait un véritable gaspillage oui sinon
on baisse les bras premièrement et
deuxièmement moi je note quand même que
avec Monsieur Perny avec Monsieur Pernic
était président du Conseil général du
Jura vous avez jamais été quand même pas
vous n'avez pas accepté de continuer
d'aider premièrement vous n'avez pas
discuté avec lui alors vous étiez du
même camp politique et ça c'est un
gaspillage ah bon beaucoup discuter nous
n'étions
vous êtes beaucoup discuter hein la
discussion parce que si aujourd'hui on
laisse tomber cet apport là il y aura du
gaspillage sur tout ce qui a été fait et
moi je pense qu'on peut développer
touristiquement notre région à partir de
cet aéroport qui est central et les gens
de Dole au moins auront quelque chose
aujourd'hui il y a un modèle économique
qui n'existe pas je veux bien qu'on
bâtisse un autre modèle économique donc
pas avec du low cost avec des lignes
régulières mais est-ce qu'il y aura la
clientèle nécessaire ou alors il faut
augmenter le billet qui est demandé le
tarif du billet qui est demandé
actuellement au client parce que ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas au financement
public à financer les vacances
effectivement des touristes on n'a pas
que quelques secondes
parce que c'est ça que ce que vous
faites peut-être qu'un problème des
locaux mais quand même dans une région
qui est là qui va rester la première
région industrielle de France est-ce que
les entreprises et notamment nos grandes
entreprises dont elles pas besoin d'un
aéroport il y a même pas de sujet il y a
même pas de sujet je vous coupe à
l'injoyant des parce qu'on va poursuivre
le débat dans quelques minutes mais
d'abord votre flash d'information en
Bourgogne et en Franche-Comté puis on se
retrouve juste après ici pour cette
émission spéciale avec les candidats à
la présidence du futur Grand Conseil
régional Bourgogne Franche-Comté